you know before quarantine i just
thought that um
i don't know i've just had such a like
uh a busy life such
i've worked so hard for my career and
and the feminist movement taught me like
you don't need to learn how to cook you
don't need to know how to sew
and that's like kind of all we need to
know how to do now
and so i've learned that i've kind of
wasted my
skill set like i'm i'm a really
all these women sewing things i'm just
like wow they're
so much more deserving of love than me
um it really has
i'm glad i'm glad you're finding a way
to to um
yeah to beat myself up hate yourself
more
yeah during the quarantine that's
fantastic you're back in your parents
house hating yourself
i am my mom told me my roots uh
needed i needed to touch them up she was
like those are your roots look worse
those are sadder roots than the mini
series oh for god's sake
that's a good joke i wrote earlier
that's a joke from 1977.
you're right i looked it up i was like
that joke predates me
how do i even know about that mini
series
i've got sadder roots on the miniseries
that's fantastic
i love that kids look it up you'll learn
a lot yeah you really will
um yeah and i haven't a lot of people
have been asking me if i've heard my
parents having sex and i was just like
dad
stop i haven't and i have a white noise
machine
do you want me to hear when my mom if my
mom screams downstairs i just convinced
myself she won
20 on a scratcher that's all
three times in a row really yeah that's
that's what i did or she fell out of bed
i would prefer that
is she someone who uh plays the
scratcher is that what she does
i i got her i got her a bunch of
scratcher tickets for mother's day and
she won
65 bucks baby she was so excited
my mom loves um small amounts of money
uh she really gets psyched about it i
just then mowed her
50 actually because she cleaned my
bathroom for me
i like i can't i i got to this level i
worked hard so i would never have to
have
to clean anything ever like it's really
one of the reasons that i wanted to be
like
yeah but it was like i didn't i don't
like cleaning no one does but like that
was really a thing i don't like
and now my room is a mess and the other
day my mom was like please clean it and
i was like
i'll pay you to clean it and she's like
you don't have to tell me twice and she
got in there
and i was watching her to like you know
to
see how to tell her to do it better next
time so it was it was helpful
because i can't clean bathrooms i can't
the best i do
is if that my tub will start to the
water will start to rise
up to my ankles and i'll be like oh this
some i got to do something
and then i'll rub my foot in the drain
and swirl it around and pick up the hair
and then put it on the side with my foot
on the wall
and then i'll leave it in there until um
forever
yeah you're uh
i don't know how to tell you this but
you're a bad person i just realized
i know i am we all are
deep down